نجوم كره القدم يودعون بيكه وبولس التامين
على قدم ميسي وماذا تفعل احتفاليه رونالدو
في مانشستر سيتي هذه الاخبار وغيرها
يقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
وضع العديد من نجوم كره القدم حول العالم
مدافع برشلونه المعتزل جيران بيكيه عبر
حساباتهم على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لاعبوا باريس سان جيرمان الحالي وزميله
بيكا السابق في برشلونه نيمار وثقه من
خلال الانستغرام متابعته للحظات الوداع
اما نجر مانشستر يونايتد السابق
رئيس برشلونه الجديد في طريقه اليكم من
بين المودعين ايضا الامير فيصل بن تركي
رئيس نادي النصر السابق والذي شكر
رقم جديد يتصدر الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
هذه المره ليو الاغلى على مستوى العالم في
التامين على جزء من الجسم
باريس سان جيرمان الحالي وبرشلونه السابق
يملك بوليصه تامين بقيمه 900 مليون دولار
على قدمه اليسرى فقط
وتفوق ميسي على منافسه مثل كريستيانو
رونالدو وقت
قائمه اغلى لاعبي كره القدم المؤمن عليهم
في العالم
تستمر احتفاليات النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو في غزو ملاعب كره القدم
هذه المره وصلت الى صفوف الغريب مانشستر
سيتي
لاعب السيتي تحت واحدا 21 عاما بتقليد
احتفاليه رونالدو خلال مباراه قطبي
مانشستر والتي انتهت بفوز السيتزن في
سداسيه مقابل هدف سجلت رخيص اربعه اهداف
منه غاريث بيل يحقق انجازا غير مسبوق حيث
سجل هدف التعادل في الوقت الاضافي وتالق
زميله الحارس جون ماركاتي في اكلات الترجي
لوس انجلوس الى التتويجي بلقب الدوري
الامريكي للمراه الاولى في تاريخ النادي
[موسيقى]